bonsoir merci de prendre le temps de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
sur quels motifs précisément jérôme
rodriguez at il été interpellés
alors il ya trois personnes qui ont été
interpellées dont j'ai géré mon abri
guez d'une personne qui m'a désigné
alors sur quel motif son organisation
d'une manifestation non déclarée ce qui
est complètement ridicule puisqu'il se
trouvait ces trois personnes se trouvent
à proximité de la rue saint-honoré
n'était pas inséré dans une
manifestation
évidemment comme je redemande rugueuse
et ciblée en permanence par les forces
de l'ordre ils ont procédé à leur
arrestation sans aucune raison voilà le
motif ces organisation d'une
manifestation non déclarée mais
évidemment
la vega en fête organisé une quelconque
manifestation pour agacer revendiqué sur
les réseaux sociaux comme l'un des
organisateurs du convoi de la liberté
convoi qui avait été interdite par la
préfecture de police de paris
chargés au moindre pièce ne sait jamais
en fait revendiqué comme un co
organisateurs du convoi de la liberté il
a dit qu'il soutenait en fait ce convoi
de la liberté les rendez vous compte
qu'il était par la rue saint-honoré ils
étaient trois personnes on ne l'est pas
du tout dans le mouvement fait du convoi
de la liberté ils étaient juste là pour
la levée ce qui est complètement son
droit en france on n'interdit pas aux
gens de simples citoyens de fines et
dévoila de films ou de la levée mais
n'étaient que trois personnes et je le
répète alors qu'il a hérité
intermédiaire organisait pour
organisation d'une manifestation non
déclarée il n'a faire en fait que
relayer comme il le fait habituellement
sur ses lives un événement là en
l'occurrence le combat pour la liberté
mais en aucun cas ces essais à
l'organisateur est ce que vous avez pu
entrer en contact avec lui ou est-ce
qu'il se trouve ce soir
alors là alors là je là je suis à porte
maillot le commissariat vient de
m'appeler donc là je me rends au
commissariat de police du 7ème
arrondissement puisque les trois
personnes qui ont été interpellées une
manière abusive sans la garde à vue au
commissariat de police etienne l'aller
j'avais juste me rendre quoi et quelles
vont être les prochaines étapes dans ce
dossier
lors la prochaine étape déjà si les
entretiens avec la personne qui m'a dit
en garde à vue et ensuite d'avoir les
auditions mais compte tenu que
l'infraction qui est reprochée est puni
d'une peine d'emprisonnement
inférieure à un an la garde à vue ne
peut duré que 24 heures donc pour qu'au
bout de 24 heures plusieurs solutions
soit il relâchait rodriguez les
personnes avec qui il était nous soit il
est déféré au parquet au tribunal d'auch
qui s'y met là en l'état
n'ayant pas tous les éléments
d'information
je ne vois pas en fait pour quel motif
il sera déferré c'est juste en fait de
la pression psychologique de la
répression policière champion depuis
trois ans en fait les manifestants
notamment gérant mon handicap
sont ciblés et souvent en fait ce sont
des personnes qui sont arrêtés qui sont
complets sont relâchés après avoir été
déféré au parquet on essaye en fait de
faire à la rencontre de la violence
psychologique
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation sur arte france david lee
baskin faire des avocats de jérôme
rodriguez